for millions of workers around the world
the first of May is their day in the
late 19th century American labor unions
were fed up fed up with being overworked
in dangerous conditions and with little
pay so in 1884 the federation of
organized trades and labor unions met in
Chicago and had one major demand an
eight-hour workday and on May 1st 1886
over 300,000 American workers went on
strike three days later thousands of
strikers met in Haymarket Square where a
riot broke out between cops and workers
a bomb was thrown into the crowd killing
several people it was called the
Haymarket massacre and today May 1st is
known as International Workers day while
every country's workers have a different
history behind May Day they all
commemorate those who have and continue
to give their lives for workers justice